[Musique]
je redéroule le
fil encore et
encore comment pu en arriver
[Musique]
là Rio juste le nom ça fait RVER mais
proposer de
rejoindreavion tu fais
là
tu veux je me sente coupable quitte
cette fille ça me gêne vis-àvis de
Delphine grand Mathieu incorruptible
monsieur bien sous tout rapport c'est ça
Delphine passe pour une conne et toi tu
dis rien tu cautionnes en fait c'est mon
ami depuis toujours il nous a sauvé la
vie tu t'oches encore une fois de mon
mari je CR de
yeux j'y crois pas une seule seconde
delphine est incapable de
ça regarde-moi tu doutes de moi
non non c'est qui
alors tout ça c'est à cause de
lui tu étais où tu la connaissais tu
crois pas que tu me dois une
explication si c'était lui qui lu
faisait porter le
chapeau à qui t'a
parlé je ne sais plus qui a dit
improbable à toutes les chances de se
produire qu'est-ce ça je
[Musique]
sais